So I'm here tonight talking to Howard
Bloom,
who's a fascinating person and an author
of many books and a polymath of sorts
and we've known each other by electronic
communication for quite a long time.
It's,
it's something exceeding a decade,
but we've never met either in person or
electronically by video until now.
And I'm Howard is definitely,
well he's a singular sort of person and
he has a very broad range of knowledge
as broad as anyone I've ever encountered
I would say.
And so what I'm going to do first is
turn this over to him so that he can
tell you a little bit about himself and
about what he's done.
And then we're going to talk about his
newest book,
which is called how I accidentally
started the sixties and then.
Well we're going to see where it goes
from there.
So Howard,
thanks for showing up here and let's,
let's see where we can go.
So why don't you tell everybody about
yourself.
Well,
it's a pleasure to see you in person
because I think it's been about 14
years,
maybe 15 years that we've known each
other,
put together a science of the soul
initiative a long time ago.
And,
and you were one of those kinds of
enough to sign on.
Um,
but,
uh,
I am the author of six books.
The first book is called the Lucifer
principle.
I scientific expedition into the forces
of history and even though it's about 25
years old,
um,
people are buying it because it feels
like it was written yesterday for
tomorrow and people call it their Bible.
The second book is global brain,
the evolution of mass mind from the Big
Bang to the 21st century.
And the office of the Secretary of
defense in the United States,
the reform based on one of the,
on that book and brought in people from
the State Department that the Energy
Department,
Darpa,
IBM,
and Mit.
Um,
the third book is called the genius of
the beast.
A radical revision of capitalism.
I preferred its original title,
which was reinventing capitalist,
importing soul,
the machine.
And that book,
the man who runs Dubai,
the shake who runs Dubai,
a named array source,
after one of the,
after that book,
the,
uh,
his former minister of development who's
under buys ruling council and runs a
$33,000,000,000
sovereign real estate company that built
the tallest building in the world,
went in front of the Arabian business
and Economic Forum and told them there
was a book that I particularly resonate
with.
It's the genius of the beast and it
contains the future of Dubai.
And he proceeded to read passages from
that book and Dr a Dot p Dot j Columbia,
11th president of India said that that
book is a visionary creation and this is
despite the fact that the sheikh runs do
by his former minister of development.
And Dr Robert Bull j column are all
Muslims and I'm a Zionist atheist.
So if there's any sign of hope for peace
in this world,
that's it.
I've done lots and lots of other things.
Just a few months ago,
I co founded and shared the Asian space
technology summit with a large groups of
representatives from China,
the Chinese Academy of Space Technology,
and from,
uh,
England space program.
I've done the weirdest variety of things
you've ever seen in your life.
Oh,
and I should not forget,
once upon a time I found it.
I knew nothing about popular culture.
I found that the biggest pr firm in the
music industry,
I use my scientific tools since it's my
background is science,
my life science,
my bones,
and my flesh,
our science.
And it became the most successful
theater on the firm and the record
industry.
So I worked with Michael Jackson,
prince,
Bob Marley,
but middle or ACDC Aerosmith,
kiss queen,
run DMC,
Billy Joel,
Paul,
Simon,
Peter,
Gabriel,
David Byrne,
run DMC,
grandmaster flash and the furious five.
Little things like that can't really
only too crazy biography you'd think
you'd have to think that someone is
making that up if you didn't know it was
true.
And then you also accidentally started
the sixties apparently.
Yes.
And it was reading that book about a
week ago and thought,
what did you think of it?
Oh,
I thought it was very funny.
It was,
it was,
it was.
I also thought it was remarkable that
you managed to have a foreword by or I
wasn't a former and I don't think it was
commentary by Timothy leary.
Yes.
Well,
let me tell you how that came about.
There I was a.
well it was about 1981 and I started to
go back to my science.
Yes,
I was running low successful pr from the
music industry.
Yes.
We were still on the ess.
We were establishing,
taking unknowns like prince and
establishing them as major stars or Joan
Jett who've been turned down by 23
record companies and we made her double
platinum in a year and a half.
Um,
but I finally got a little time for you
to go back to my science.
And then,
um,
uh,
I was taking a bunch of journalists out
to long island to see reo speedwagon.
And a bunch of them said,
bloom.
All these ideas.
You keep talking about us.
You need to write a book and one of them
will talk me under his wing and actually
mentored me,
Timothy White,
who wrote for the Associated Press and
rolling stone.
Um,
so I started working on a book in 1984,
about 1988.
I had gotten up and running and written.
The first chapter is on a vacation and
then I came down for two things
happened.
First,
I really needed to get out of publicity
in the music industry.
I have satisfied all of my intellectual
questions because there were a set of
questions I was answering,
answering what are the mass exhilaration
for the mass exodus sees the mass
emotions that are the forces of history,
that power historical change.
That's what I was after.
And you see that in miniature with the
Beatles or with Michael Jackson or
prince.
So I gotten this far as I could.
I mean youtube would approach me to
represent them.
I wasn't interested.
I'm Mick Jagger,
had sent an emissary talk about
representing him.
I wasn't interested.
I'd been through all of this already.
Let me ask you a couple of questions
there.
So,
I mean,
the first question would be,
I think,
how,
what is it that you had done that had
prepared you for that and how and how
did you manage it?
So I guess that's two questions,
but also what did you,
what did you learn from all of that?
These are very great questions to
prepare me for this Martin Gardner from
the time I was 10,
I was reading two books a day,
um,
my teachers say to me because I was
reading a book under the desk at all
times and never,
ever paid attention to them and many of
these science books and I read the
scientific American from cover to cover
and Martin Gardner who is a
mathematician,
had a column called Mathematical Games.
And I learned what I know from
mathematical games.
It taught me certain techniques I was
able to bring in.
So the record industry.
So that's a hell of a stretch.
I mean singular story.
So how.
Okay,
so elaborate on that.
Well,
what it taught is how to look for
correlations and more than a
mathematical techniques for finding
correlations.
It gave you a gut feel of what a
correlation looks like so that you
didn't have to go off to a world of
mathematics that was so arcane,
that had no relationship to reality.
You could take the search for
correlations into the real world.
Um,
I listened to music as obsessively from
the time I was about 10 years old,
my uncle and I used to stand next to a
huge old burl would radio that was as
tall as I was at the time and it had a
giant speaker in Jordan in those days,
12 inch speakers.
Nobody to receive wellborn speakers,
but it had one.
And we've listened to the classical
music station in Canada because we were
in buffalo on the border and we would
compete to see who can identify a piece
of music by its first four notes.
While often we can both identify the
piece of music by first note.
However,
it was all classical music.
It was rough,
Montereau,
bartow,
Beethoven,
Stravinsky.
I'm Mozart,
stuff like that.
So I can't really say that I was
properly prepared because I was hated by
the other kids my age in Buffalo,
New York,
and my parents didn't have any time for
me.
So I was an outcast and the the crowd of
people that shut me out,
listen to popular music.
So popular music.
What started is with Elvis Presley,
what was around before Elvis Presley and
then moved on.
That was alien music for me and I wasn't
the least bit interested in it and.
But in the 1970 [inaudible],
late 19 sixties and early 19 seventies,
I knew I had fellowships at for Grad
schools.
I'm in what is now called neuroscience.
At that point,
it was a do it yourself proposition.
I was going to have to take courses in
the med school at Columbia and flipped
them together with courses in psychology
at Columbia and make my own neuroscience
because there were no neuroscience
courses,
but I had four fellowships to do this
and I realized that Grad school would be
Auschwitz for the mind.
Why?
Because I was fascinated by these
ecstatic mass passions that young people
that boost people out of themselves,
but lift them into something much bigger
than themselves,
a deep need that every human has to feel
at some point a part of something much
bigger than his or herself,
and those are the mass passions that
create historical change.
They are the forces of history and I was
not going to get to study mass passions.
I was not going to get to make contact
with mass fashions.
If I went onto win academic career,
I'd be spending the rest of my life
giving paper and Pencil tests to 22
college students in exchange for a
psychology credit.
Now,
exactly how much ecstatic experience are
you going to see in a classroom of that
sort with type paper and pencil tests?
Zero.
The entire phenomena I wanted to
understand would not be there anywhere
in my life,
so I took advantage of the fact that I
had basically been kidnapped and my
junior year by the poet in residence at
Nyu who had said he'd said,
look low when everybody will hear us out
of the room.
Close the door.
I know I need to talk to you.
Well Jordan,
that means a balling out,
right?
So I waited until everybody left.
I shut the door.
I sat down in the your about to be
balled out chair and the poet and
residents said to me,
look,
last year I asked you to be on the staff
of Literary magazine.
You didn't even show up this year.
You are the literary magazine.
You don't even have a faculty advisor.
The minute you walk out that door,
your it now walk out that door.
And I walked out the door looking
totally baffled because I hated literary
magazines.
They were the most boring things you
would ever seen.
You could have a group of Vikings,
each of whom had drunk a quart of Ale,
um,
bond funking up against the wall and
bonking each other.
And if you put a literary magazine and
the room,
that Pale blue cover and the mist chosen
type would make either put everybody to
sleep instantly what would drive them
out of the room.
So I looked very confused in a student,
walked up to me and said,
you look troubled about something.
Can I help you?
Why don't I take you down for a cup of
coffee?
I didn't know what a cup of coffee once
I had grown up with lab rats and and
hamsters.
I'm not with human beings,
but I followed him obediently.
Now listers.
And when we sat down at the coffee shop
and I ordered water and he ordered
coffee,
he said,
if you could do anything you want with
this magazine,
what would it be?
And I said a picture book so that,
that Jordan,
I've learned that question,
that question is a very valuable tool.
So I turned it into experimental and
graphics magazine and it was a wild hit
and it was a wild hit,
not just on campus where they doubled
our budget for the second issue.
It was a wild hit in the art directorial
community.
I think you covered that in,
in how I started accidentally started
the 66.
I think.
So what that allowed me to do,
um,
is when I,
and my wife was putting pressure on me,
she had had a previous husband who was
assuming she was tired of having student
husbands.
She made it clear and it kind of sort of
voucher a way that if I went off to Grad
School at Columbia,
I could kiss her goodbye.
Not a nice idea after three years of
marriage.
So with all these pressures on me,
um,
I threw my lot in with the artists that
I had assembled for this magazine.
We,
we formed an art studio and the first
year we are in $75 a piece,
which is,
which is just enough to get you food and
possibly a little bit of shelter in New
York City.
But eventually I made the cover of art
direction magazine.
I invented a new animation technique for
NBC TV and most important by studio did
all of the graphics for ABC Seven FM
stations at a time when there was a
revolution taking place in radio.
There was this brand new form of radio
called rock radio or album radio or
progressive radio.
And with ditch witch,
just rocky,
so it actually play what they want it.
And I was there because ABC seven FM
stations all converted to this new
progressive format and they used me,
I my art studio to get that across to
kids all over the ice.
So yeah,
you will respond to all that once I got
to thank you for that because I listened
to Lee Memorial and FM stations a lot
when I was a kid.
And so a lot.
I mean lots of people did,
but I didn't know you were.
You had a hand in that.
So that was very good thing.
Well I thank you for the thanks.
I had a hand in that and they abc asked
me to form an advertising agency to
handle all of their advertising and
Jordan.
I didn't want to get involved in time
buying.
That was just too dry for me.
But because I was walking into.
We did one other thing.
There was a new magazine with a bunch of
Harvard kids.
It was a monthly version of the annual
Harvard Lampoon.
It was called the National Lampoon and
my art studio art directed the first
seven issues that.
But it was ABC pgl roof.
His start there,
right?
Yes,
exactly.
And I acted in a Michael O'donoghue
script that we did for the Evergreen
Review,
um,
which was leading a Bohemian publication
of the time.
It's art director was one of those
people who had called me,
um,
after we saw the Washington Square
review,
the student literary and Graphics
magazine that,
that I've been putting together,
but they,
the promotion person at ABC was
extremely kind to me.
And every time I walked in I'd hear
Carole King or James Taylor who were the
biggest people in rock music at the time
on the speakers on the floor.
And she would do things like,
I mean,
she was just clue me in.
She was bringing me into the rock and
roll world one day,
for example,
she said,
we're going to have,
we're going to have a live performance
to studio b by a penis.
And I'm
wondering,
I give you two tickets.
So I took her two tickets.
I went down to my art studio on Fourth
Street and second avenue in the East
village and my,
my leading artists was just a brilliant,
brilliant a cartoonist,
and I invited him to come to this event
with me.
We went to the event.
The Piano's took to the stage.
My artists sat next to me and from the
minute the pianist played his first
cord,
my artists was on his feet going,
wow,
you have the yahoo.
And totally embarrassing me.
I mean,
I wanted to crawl under the seat and
become absolutely invisible.
The pianist on stage was out in the
genre.
What I failed to get was that my artist
was giving Elton John the energy he
needed to do the very kind of expanded
performance that takes you out of
yourself and makes you feel part of
something bigger than yourself.
That I was trapped trying to track down
using things like William James,
the varieties of religious experience
and taking advantage of my,
my special vantage point.
Um,
how,
why do you think,
you know,
you're,
you,
there's cars,
there's a kind of a contradictory
narrative that runs through that story,
which is that,
you know,
when you're a kid you were sort of
isolated,
you were booking more scientifically
oriented,
but at the same time you obviously had
a,
what,
what would you call it,
a,
a feel for ecstatic experience and like
was that,
was that a consequence of your
participation in the counterculture in
the sixties or was that something that
emerged even before that?
It was something that emerged probably
between the age of 10 and 12.
It probably came from the fact that I
was suffering serious social
deprivation.
I really,
I had one friend at a time and that's
about as much as I had and I was,
I was an indispensable figure when it
came time to beat somebody up because I
was the target.
Um,
how.
Okay.
So That's interesting too because that
also,
I mean,
it isn't obvious how you get from that
position to being interested in ecstatic
experiences per se.
So how,
what,
what's the connection there with your
rather like,
what would you call it?
Isolated childhood experiences,
do you think?
I mean you said it had something partly
to do with music,
which makes perfect,
perfect sense to me because music is
almost a,
what would you say?
It's an unerring gateway into that
ecstatic experience,
right?
And for,
for very complex reasons.
I'd like to talk to you about that a
little bit,
but it,
it isn't obvious why someone who was
more scientifically oriented say would
also make that leap over to the more
mystical end of things.
And then of course pursue it through pop
culture.
So you laid out your surprising
involvement,
literary magazine,
your transformation of that into what
was essentially a visual art
publication,
your entry into the world of radio and
then into rock.
I don't want to lose that thread because
that also leads to your pr firm,
and I presume we're getting to that,
but what deconditioned or anything that
you can put your finger on you,
you associated there also with like
being physically bullied and being a
social outcast,
but why did that give you the hunger for
that experience,
for that ecstatic?
Well,
remember back to the days of the 19
sixties in the 19 seventies when sleep
deprivation was a new discovery and then
back in the 19 nineties and early two
thousands,
Jaak Panksepp took that a step further
and in his studies of rapid behavior,
he discovered that if he deprived a
bunch of child Rhett's,
little rats,
baby rats,
if he deprives them of the ability to
play and didn't give them access to each
other as peers until they become adults.
They suffered play deprivation and they
spent just as much time playing with
each other as adults as they would have
spent playing with each other.
Have they been allowed to as children?
Okay,
so I want to make a quick lateral move
there and we'll get back to that.
You know,
I've been thinking about these,
these strange,
modern manifestations of identity
fantasy or that's what it looks to me
like these people who are playing out,
what do they call them,
other kids,
and playing with their identities and a
really fantasy based way.
Sometimes I wonder if part of that isn't
a consequence of play deprivation in
childhood.
Well,
that sounds.
That sounds like a distinct possibility.
But remember,
Herman has said that there are somewhere
deep dark in the mind.
There is a closet with 10,000
hidden personalities.
One of the things that I discovered were
going to get out of chronological order,
but one of the things that I discovered
when I first became full time involved
with rock and roll was the story of
Alice Cooper.
And the story of Alice Cooper reveal
something about the question that you
just raised.
Alice Cooper was a little bit like me
when he was a kid.
His mom used to dress up in a suit every
day and he was a gawky thin with a huge
nose.
Um,
I was walking in with a huge nose.
I can identify and never wore suits.
Now.
And he was always a teacher's pet and
the result was the other kids hated him
and he was kicked around and beaten and,
and excluded the way that I'd been
kicked around and beaten and excluded.
Then one day a neighbor was at in his
kitchen who was into a weegee board and
making contact with spirits through the
Wigi board.
Um,
so,
uh,
spirit allegedly contacted her and said,
I am the ghost of a witch who was burned
at the stake in the 16th century and,
or 17th century.
And you pointing to Alice,
I'm pointing to his saying was runs for
an ea at the time,
pointing to Vince.
You are my moderate reincarnation.
And My name is Alice Cooper.
Now,
when,
when Vince for an ea one onstage and
address with Mascara at a high school
talent night for the very first time
playing his own music,
chopping up baby dolls with an ax,
which is the more real person Vince for
an EA,
the shy little kid dressed up in a suit
who gave apples to his teacher or Alice
Cooper,
the person on stage who comes to life
with an ecstatic identity that makes
them a surfer on the back of those mass
passions,
those mass exhilaration that make the
forces of history.
Well Alice of the two,
they're both real people and they're
both inside events for an ea,
but the one that's in there that has the
greatest passionate intensity is the
Alice Cooper.
Not the Vince for an ai and that's why
they'll.
He had been picked on and none of the
kids in his school had liked him.
The minute he finished his first
performance,
all the football guys who used to beat
the crap out of him,
surge down to the foot of the stage and
volunteer to be parts of his band and
when he was super famous.
Some of those guys were still mainstays
of his band.
We carry many selves round inside of us
and my job in pr was to find people who
deserved to be iconic and then to
explain to them,
first of all,
I will not.
If you think that I as your publicist,
I'm going to crash in an artificial mask
and image and through that make you a
star.
I'm going to get you an appointment with
my best competitor immediately.
You'll be with them.
And um,
if you're going to work with me,
you have to understand something.
The music you make as a human soul that
comes from the very soul of you and what
happens to you when you go out on stage
and feel as if yourself leaves you and
you are danced like a puppet or like a
puppet on a string like a marionette on
stage.
The force that moves you,
that's one of the gods inside of you
that is your soul and what you're
experiencing with that audience.
It's a soul exchange.
If you're willing to put up with the
fact that music is not about marketing,
music is not about product.
Music is not about downloads,
music is about the human soul that I
will work with you
and quite the statement for a Zionist
atheists chew.
Yes.
It really is whole and not manner that,
you know,
I listened to Alice Cooper a lot when I
was a kid and still now especially that
record a welcome to my nightmare,
which I think is an absolute classic.
You know,
there's a couple of pop songs on it
which,
which I think,
I mean record companies did that a fair
bit on,
on,
on concept albums.
You know,
they'd throw a pop hit on there,
but as a concept album it's brilliant
and it's really well arranged and it's
really not horrifying exactly because
that's not exactly right,
but it's unbelievably dramatic.
I would say theatrical in,
in the best way and I really think it's
a work of genius that welcome to my
nightmare.
So and I,
I had no idea that,
that that was Alice Cooper's background,
although I did hear that he was the
child of a minister.
Is that also correct?
No,
no,
no.
His father was in the aerospace industry
in Arizona.
Oh,
big aerospace territory.
Right.
But a lot of kids who were turned on to
Alice Cooper and were turned on by
shock.
Bands like that were the children of a
ministers,
the children of deeply religious people.
The religious right.
Bringing out the other side of things.
He did things right.
He's obviously the precursor of people
like Marilyn Manson.
Yes,
exactly.
I'm Marilyn Manson was to sort of cheap,
even though Marilyn Manson was kind
enough to be good.
To me,
Marilyn Manson was a kind of cheap a
takeoff on Alice Cooper didn't have the
staying power that Alice seems to have
had.
But the point is that I.
One of the things that I told you,
if you are going to be my client,
as you just don't,
you don't just tell your audience or
assault,
you owe your audience your life.
Now,
Jordan had told me 20 years to
articulate what I meant by that.
Um,
and it's simply that if you deserve to
be a superstar,
then you just,
you will become an iconic figure.
And 12 year old kids will paste posters,
his view on their bedroom walls and you
will be,
you know,
the concept of the Trellis.
You grow a tomato plant on a trellis.
Well,
you will be the Trellis on which people
row you will be the role model.
So your life is one of the most
important things that you have to offer.
But I wasn't just after the superficial
life I was after I was after this.
When you sit down,
have an afternoon,
let's say 2:00
in the afternoon with a blank computer
screen or a blank piece of paper and you
need to write a lyric.
You feel as if you could.
You don't know how you've ever written a
lyric in your life.
You certainly know you can't write
another one again and by 4:00
in the afternoon on a good day,
there's a lyric in front of you by 4:00
in the afternoon are really,
really rare day.
That lyric is so perfect in itself,
but it feels like it wrote itself
through you.
When you go onstage,
if you see the doc,
the pupils of the audience dilating,
if you see their faces melting,
losing individual characteristics.
If you see their energy fusing into a
collective energy rather than just
individual energies,
and if that collective force reaches a a
pseudopod out to you and hooks into
something inside of you that's bigger
than yourself and again,
you'll feel like an empty pipe and
something inside you is transmographers
all of this energy and flooding it back
down to the audience and reverberate
Tory circuit and you have an out of body
experience.
You Watch yourself from the ceiling as
your dance.
That self inside of you,
the dances you onstage.
That is your fucking Goddamn soul and
that's my my and tend to find and that's
what I intend to introduce you to.
Why?
Because you are about to become an icon
and if you become an icon,
you have to be a force that takes
hundreds of thousands or even tens of
millions of kids who feel lost in the
world who don't dare express their
feelings because there are no except
socially acceptable words for their and
who
feel crazy,
isolated and alone,
and you by revealing what's deep inside
of you will validate what's deep inside
of them.
So I think you had the other made the
other shoe drop for me then because you
know you're talking about that at least
in part,
you're talking about that ecstatic
experience as the,
as the necessary counter position to
isolation and abandonment,
loneliness and all of those things,
which,
which I think is a very,
a very reasonable way of thinking about
it.
It's like meaning as the antidote to
isolation and tragedy and malevolence
for that matter.
And music is no.
I've thought deeply about music.
I've,
I've tried to figure out why it has what
it represents and why it has the effects
that it has.
And I think,
and this is a neuroscientific view of it
to some degree,
and you know,
it seems to me that it's better to think
about the world as,
as something that consists of patterns
rather than as something that consists
of objects.
So an object would actually be a pattern
that sustains itself across time.
It's not all that very,
very good insight.
I get applause for that.
Thank you.
And so,
so then you think,
well,
for you,
you can even think about the way the
visual system works this way.
So,
you know,
we tend to think that there's a world
out there and then there's an image of
that world projected onto our retina and
then the images is reconstructed,
say in our visual cortex.
And then we,
uh,
then we,
we can become conscious of that image
and planner actions and in consequence
of that.
But that isn't how it works.
The way it works is that there are
patterns in the world and then the
patterns are shifted into patterns of
light of illumination.
And then those are shifted into patterns
of neural activity on the retina.
of neural conductance,
the optical nerves,
and then patterns in the visual Cortex,
and then those are expressed as patterns
of movement.
So it's all the transformations of
patterns and the meeting of a visual
perception is the pattern of action that
it gives rise to,
which is why you need a body meant to be
able to perceive.
And I think the reason that music speaks
so deeply to us of fundamental meaning
is because it's actually the most
representative art form.
You know?
Because people think about it in some
senses,
the least representative art form.
I don't think that's right at all.
I think it represents the reality that
exists in a profound sense beyond what
our senses revealed to us moment to
moment and so it puts people then when
you're moving to the music and we were
all moving to the music or when you're
dancing,
let's say with someone else and you're
and you're as pairs and you're all
dancing together.
It's that the patterns of the cosmos,
so to speak,
manifesting themselves as the patterns
of the music manifesting themselves as
the patterns of your body and in
syncopation with everyone else.
So it's also a symbolic representation
of a harmonious and ideal society.
And there it is something that's beyond
us.
And so it's,
it's interest.
So I get it.
So,
so partly what you're saying,
if I understand you,
is that for you there,
the ecstatic collective experience that
was associated with music,
for example in pop music perhaps was you
could see it out very clearly as the
antidote to painful isolation.
And,
and I mean,
one of the things that struck me as,
as,
as struck me as near miraculous about
music,
especially in a rather nihilistic and
atheistic society,
is that it really does fill the void
that was left by the death of God.
And it's partly because you cannot
rationally critique music.
You know,
it speaks to you.
It speaks of meaning.
And no matter what you say about it,
no matter how cynical you are,
you cannot put a crow bar underneath
that and lifted up and,
and,
and toss it aside.
And music was so,
such a powerful cultural force in the
sixties and the seventies and
overwhelmingly.
Yeah,
powerful force.
So the other,
the other element is very important to
this music is the voice of a subculture.
So when you tell 100 million kids who
failed utterly isolated and alone that
they,
that their experiences have not been
reflected in the experience of any other
person on earth,
that in fact they are not alone.
Layer a movement.
Um,
you give a subculture,
a voice and you can see that with,
well,
when I finally got into working with
music,
one of the first things I did was work
with country and western music.
Now Jordan,
uh,
I worked with a company called dot
records.
I was hired by a Gulf of western to
found a public artist relations
departments where there 14 record
companies.
And one of those companies was not
records and dot records was number three
on the country charts and that it was
with third place company and he wanted
to be number one,
uh,
in country and western music now when I
was a child when I was about three and a
half years old,
I woke up on a Sunday before anybody
else in the house,
so had woken up,
went out to the front room where there
was sunlight,
which I didn't get to see as often as
I'd like and turned on the radio and
because it was 6:00
in the morning or something like that,
what I got were from reports and country
and Western music.
This was in 19,
19,
46 or something like that,
or 1947.
And I immediately knew that that music
was alien to me and I knew that it was
the music of another subculture would
not necessarily be kind to the
subculture from which I came.
So I never liked country music.
But in the 19 seventies when I got this
position with Gulf and western,
one of the things I crusaded for the
hardest was country and western music
because I felt that these people had a
right to express their identity.
I felt they had a right to get beyond
the ghetto of the Bible belt,
which is where they were kept.
And where are they were suppressed.
It was an era of subculture is finding
themselves and expressing their right to
exist.
It started with
music really does seem to have that
binding capacity,
you know,
and I think there's also something
neurological that,
because tell me what you think about
this,
if this is in accordance with your
observations,
but it seems to me that the music that
people listen to as their catalyzing
their adult identity,
say between the ages of about 14,
15 to 20,
you know,
there's a,
there's a real intense,
um,
period of neural pruning that occurs at
the end of adolescence.
So you get an endless amount of neural
neural pruning after,
uh,
after you're born in the early stages of
infancy because you have a lot of neural
connections and then a lot of them you
kind of tie into your childhood,
sell twice as many neurons as you will
actually need,
right?
Right.
Exactly.
And so,
so you're,
you're a massive possibility and then
you dye into your actuality and then
that happens again.
It laid out lessons,
right?
Which is also in schizophrenia develops
because that process seems to go wrong
for some people,
but as you're dying into that adult
identity,
one of the things that seems to catalyze
that is the music of your culture at
that time.
And that also seems to unite you in some
way underneath rational thought with the
people of your generation,
let's say with the people you'd have to
cooperate with and compete with.
And so there's something really deep
about that too.
That's not well understood.
And,
and,
and so I.
well,
so I don't know what you think about
the second element of that because it's
a brilliant observation.
And the second element of that is that
in your late teens,
your prefrontal cortex gets wired up.
Now,
what's the prefrontal cortex?
It's pro.
We talk about it as the center of
Administration in the brain executive
functions.
It's primary job is making you human.
What does that mean?
You would think that means encouraging
certain things like creativity and
thought,
no,
the job of the prefrontal cortex and
making you human is two,
what?
Press things?
Um,
it's too damp.
Things down.
It's to inhibit things and you are
learning which things to inhibit after
you become utterly grafted into your
subculture.
And what is one of the elements that has
grafted you when to your subculture
music.
And so what Freud would call the Super
Ego is formed to a certain extent based
on your subculture or connections that
you've developed as a team.
And again,
music helps identify that subculture of
which you feel apart.
Alright,
well,
okay,
so,
so partly what's happening there is that
because music is poetic and also it's
poetic and emotional,
let's say it also constitutes the,
the pre irrational substrate from which
the values of that subculture emerge.
So it's like the,
it's part of the mythological
substructure of the values of that
culture.
And you can make absolute sense.
Yeah,
yeah.
You can see that expressed in the lyrics
in particular where,
which lay out a system of values in some
sense,
something like hip hop
for example.
Well roughly 95 percent of the lyrics in
pop culture or about mating mating
rituals.
There were about courtship rituals.
And you as a person who is white,
the meeting has been upgraded by the
best and now includes.
Okay.
God knows what it was trying to tell us.
So at any rate
you have just emerged from childhood,
um,
your hormones,
your sexual hormones so began to act.
Girls as young as 11 can become pregnant
already.
And you were obsessed with finding your
place in the world and finding a mate
and courtship rituals mean okay,
an awful lot to you.
They're about to what they're there,
what you were about to embark on for the
next 10 years of your life at least.
Um,
and so this obsession with courtship
rituals with mating and dating and
breaking up and,
and be trail.
And all of that kind of stuff makes.
Makes absolute sense.
Right?
Exactly.
Well,
the thing is music frame style too,
because it gives you something that's in
common with your potential mate and it
also gives you a set of rather,
I wouldn't say stereotyped activities,
but at least predictable activities that
are associated with courtship and made
again,
so that would be going to concerts and
going to movies which are heavily
musically influenced and dancing and and
even discussing your,
your shared immersement in whatever that
subculture happens to be.
Right.
My guess is that at some point music
provokes oxytocin because oxytocin is
the ultimate bonding hormone and music
is a bath in the sense of human
belonging in the field,
but even if you're alone and you're
listening to Pandora or spotify,
all by yourself,
it beans you social bread and meat,
and in the in the nervous system,
the central nervous system,
everything boils down to inhibition or
excitation.
There is a hormone of excitation and
it's glutamate.
There is a hormone of inhibition and
that's the Gabba and oxytocin feeds down
into the Gaba system.
Okay.
The system that keeps you calm down,
basically it gives you a sense of peace.
Um,
now music itself,
uh,
I mean the first musical.
First I have to give you an experience
that I had that allowed me to see into
all of this.
I had already been fascinated by the
gods inside of us.
I concluded the age of 12,
that I was an atheist and if there were
no bounds and they have an above us and
know God's in the ground beneath us,
where were the gods,
will.
My parents were trying to drive,
dragged me an atheist off the high
holiday services and they were so intent
about it,
but I was literally holding onto the
doorframe of their blue fraser or by now
forgotten car and they were shredding my
socks.
They were practically tearing my shoes
off.
They were doing everything they could to
get me up to the temple.
And so I realized in that moment,
if the gods are not above,
if the gods are not below,
where are they?
They're inside my parents.
If they're inside my parents,
they're inside of me there inside of all
of us.
So my task at a basically the age of 12
to 13 became use your scientific to find
the gods inside of us.
Okay.
Well you also,
again,
you elaborated on that part of the story
that also made you a tune to those
ecstatic experiences because the case
that you've just laid out,
or I suppose we laid out together to
some degree is that perhaps it was that
the fact that you were isolated as a kid
made you even more sensitive to the
collective belonging element of music
because you were so starved for it and
then they.
The idea of the gods within that you
just laid out.
It seems to me to be very much akin to
what you described as either your tactic
or your philosophy with regards to pr
for the rock personalities because what
you said you were doing was trying to
make them reveal some of these
archetypal figures within and that that
would.
And that you were actually trying to
foster that.
Which meant in some sense you weren't
doing pr at all.
Like,
I don't know what the hell you'd call
it.
I call it secular shamanism was a name I
was never comfortable with because it's
so unscientific,
but that was the closest I can come to
what it's like dowsing for the human
soul.
What would it be?
Any good name for a PR company?
A second.
Yeah.
But I think that's a very.
Well,
I think that's a very useful way of
thinking about it because obviously one
of the hold overs from the shamanic
traditions is obviously music.
I mean,
that's just,
that's just a continuation of the same
tradition thing.
There was one very important thing that
had happened to me when I was 16 years
old,
even though I was listening,
popular kid in my school,
they voted me for two years in a row,
the chairman of the programming
committee,
which means I ran student assemblies
five days a week and I program to a
week.
Um,
so I was the emcee for these things.
And one day that you manage that and
similar be unpopular.
Uh,
that's a good question.
I think my school had very,
very minimally.
I stole.
This school was founded by an Acolyte of
John Dewey and he was behind the scenes
are actually setting the school up and
it,
you know,
schools have their popularity positions,
president,
vice president,
secretary,
treasurer,
all of that,
but my school was clever enough to start
putting functional committees together.
In your very first days at school,
your very first days of your a freshman
year now when you,
when you have kids vote for president
and vice president road for the most
popular kid in the school as the
precedent.
The second most popular kid as vice
president,
the most popular girl as secretary and
the most popular Jewish treasurer.
That's just the way it goes.
Well,
I was never aligned for any of those
positions.
I had no popularity whatsoever.
In fact,
one of my classmates actually fired with
remarkable accuracy from only 23 d way a
soccer ball directly into my face.
And believe me,
it has a lot of force distance of 20
feet.
So.
But when it comes to functional
positions,
like how do we run these school
assemblies?
The popular kids don't have a clue.
So if you bring them into a room,
if there arbitrarily,
for example,
assigned to a committee,
they will all piss on their a little
piece of territory,
they'll all stake out a position of some
kind just to establish their status in
the room and after 15 minutes.
So this one,
they've all said their piece and it
comes time to actually do something.
They're clueless,
they're silent,
they don't know what to do.
And if there is an unpopular geek like
me who at that 20 minute mark all of a
sudden has an idea,
they will glom around you even if they
don't like you.
Right?
So competence can,
can,
can step in where we're popularity
cannot go.
Yes,
that's a very well put phrase.
So,
so there I was the head of this
programming committee and one of the
kids,
one of the juniors came to me and said,
we're doing a dance.
We're,
you know,
we're setting up a dance and could you
advertise it for us?
And he didn't realize just how absurd
that statement was.
If there's a dance or a party of any
kind in buffalo,
New York.
One of the first things you have to
realize about it is I am not just
disinvited.
I haven't decided to stay as far away as
humanly possible and yet they want me to
advertise this dance.
So Jordan,
I can't dance.
I am.
I can't do a box step.
I can't do a Fox trot,
I can't do a waltz,
I can't do any of those things,
but I went onstage and put some music on
the turntable and danced and I saw the
pupils dilating of the audience.
Three hundred 50 people who hated me and
hated me for two and a half years of
that point,
their pupils were dilating,
their faces were melting.
I felt that pseudopod of energy coming
to me and through me as if I were a
pipe.
I felt it going up to something inside
of me more or less.
It had level that utterly transmogrified
it and I felt the energy being sent
back.
Every mood that I was making an I had an
out of body experience.
I saw,
I thought I was on the ceiling.
I've watched all of this from the
ceiling and apparently it looked like a
loony toon drawn on Lsd as if Chuck
Jones had been doing Tom and Jerry after
taking a very big hit of acid.
It was one of the strangest,
weirdest things you've ever seen and
when it was all over.
So that was my ecstatic experience.
When it was all over,
the audience did something that had
never done in my days at that school,
I would never do again.
So long as I was there,
it surged to the foot of the stage and
as if it had practiced this act all its
life,
it picked me up off the stage.
It put me on his shoulders,
it carried me out of the auditorium and
it carried me up the pathway to the
building above where we had our classes.
So that was my introduction.
Yeah.
And,
but this is,
that's crazy story.
Right?
And this is three years after I'd gone
off after the ecstatic experience,
knowing that it was something vital.
I mean,
I'd heard at the age of 14,
two years earlier,
I had heard that there was a book called
the varieties of the religious
experience,
and in those days we,
no Amazon,
um,
we had local bookstores and local
bookstores in Buffalo.
I mean,
give me a break,
but I finally found a copy of the
University of Buffalo Bookstore and it
felt as if William James had been laying
out a series of examples of the ecstatic
experience,
um,
with all of its delusions and
hallucinations and all the rest on a
laboratory bench.
And then saying to me,
look,
you're coming along.
Seventy years later you're going to have
scientific tools that I did not have.
This is your job.
And it was my job,
not just because William James was
giving it to me because something deep
inside of me was crying out to
understand it.
And it probably was that the privilege
of social disconnection,
the privilege of social deprivation.
Because that privilege made me
sensitive.
And it's always made me sensitive to
group behavior.
Right?
So when I was in Moscow in 2005
lecturing,
a group of quantum physicists from all
over the world,
I'm why everything they know about
quantum physics does wrong.
It's because there is no such thing as
an isolated particle.
Every particle is part of our herd,
a mob,
a group of some kind.
Um,
the quantum physicists based on the idea
that when you,
when you treat a Photon,
a single photon in a certain way,
when you split it into here's how it's
going to behave.
But if it's being measured,
that's not going to happen.
Well,
guess what?
We're constantly taking each other's
measure.
Photons are constantly taking each
other's measure because they move in
groups,
crowds and herds.
That's why a beam of sunshine comes
through your window,
not a photon.
A sunshine.
And when I finished the speech,
I was sure they were going to throw me
out of the conference because these are
all people committed deeply to quantum
physics.
And instead they sat there beaming like
a proud uncles and I could not figure
out why.
And three years later,
my collaborator in quantum physics,
uh,
at the university,
at the mathematics,
so the Russian Academy of Sciences in
Moscow Sanity Mail,
and he said,
Dr,
use your club who ran that conference
and gave you such a hard time about your
credit card,
has just published a book.
It's a new approach to quantum physics.
It's called constructive physics.
You have to get it immediately.
So I downloaded it from org.
I listened to it that afternoon on my
hour and a half walk through the park on
my way to the cafe where I do all my
work and I got all excited.
Every social concept that means every
concept that I had given in this talk
was in this book.
So Jordan,
I've had the privilege of proceedings
through life with this enormous
advantage,
social deprivation.
Then I'm still going to chase you back
to the story about the PR company,
but I have another question for you.
So you know,
you,
you are detailing out the kind of
childhood that in principle could have
left you bitter and resentful.
So why didn't it like,
why didn't that happen to you?
Why?
Because of my father,
um,
my mother was a deep pessimists.
My father was a profound optimist and I
must've had my father's genes
predominating over.
I've got them both optimism and
pessimism,
but I'm grateful for everything that's
happened in my life.
I'm working every deprivation,
you know,
I was sick in bed for 15 years and even
that turned out to be,
it was nightmarish.
It was horrible at it.
Inflicted pains for which there are no
words in the English language because I
was isolated for five years and could
not talk,
literally could not muster the energy to
move the larynx to give a single
syllable of sound.
And yet I,
it was nightmarish.
Horrible.
A monsters does.
It was.
I kind of,
I found it to international scientific
groups at that time.
I wrote three books and I learned what
it's like to be at that extreme of the
human experience.
Extreme isolation,
um,
extreme pain.
What happened?
Like,
what,
what were you suffering from?
Well,
we figured it out.
I mean,
I figured it out on my own and then
taught my doctor about it.
It's called chronic fatigue syndrome.
It's better sometimes known as Myalgic
encephalomyelitis and nobody knows what
causes it,
but in 1988,
I really had been working on my book for
a long enough to have fifth,
the first 15 chapters of my first book.
I really wanted to get out of publicity.
There's no way I could have because I
was a legend.
I mean the billboard guide to music
publicity had 20 pages of nothing but
me.
Um,
so,
you know,
your wife is not going to let you out of
a successful career and she's,
she doesn't want to lose the money.
She doesn't want to lose the status.
Um,
and all of a sudden wank.
I didn't know what was happening to me.
It was 90 degrees out and I'd be
freezing and shivering.
It was 40 degrees out and I will be
overheated.
Um,
I was,
I was losing strengths,
I was losing the strength to pick up
coat and I had no idea of what was
happening.
And I went to doctors and the doctors
had no idea of what was happening.
And I walked into my office one day.
It was the biggest pr firm in the music
industry and said to myself,
I don't know what's happening.
I could be dying,
but I'm going to be out of here in two
weeks and I'm giving you the business,
and the next day a competitor from the
west coast called and offered me a huge
amount of money for the business and I
said,
I cannot sell it to you.
I just gave it to my staff yesterday
because my word is my bond and I kept
trying to struggling to try to do normal
things.
Leon Uris,
when I finished my manuscript of the
first book,
the Lucifer principle,
a scientific expedition into the forces
of history.
I got a copy to Leon Uris,
the novelist and Leon Uris,
reddit and called on a Sunday night and
raved about it for half an hour.
So I tried to get into New York to see
him,
but I had to rent.
Are you ready for this?
Because I couldn't afford this.
I had a rental Lillo so I could lay down
in the back seat all the way into
Manhattan to see Leon and then lay down
in the back seat all the way home and
it's the world's most glamorous
limousine story.
Now.
It's not at all the world's most
glamorous limousines journey.
Eventually I learned I couldn't even do
that and eventually it became too weak
to even try because I was just lucky to
be able to get to my bathroom.
But if I tried to get to my kitchen and
extra 10 steps away,
no my body wouldn't let me do it.
And one of the lessons I learned in my
childhood again when I was 16 years old,
poetry was extremely important to me and
I learned a lesson from two poets.
One was at the St Vincent Millay and her
poem Renascence said too,
see the infinite in the tiniest of
things,
which was definitely a goal on my list.
You have to be able to comprehend the
suffering of every human on the face of
this planet under every extreme
circumstance.
And I expanded that to mean you have to
come to understand not just the
suffering,
but the point of view of every one who
comes from a culture that's so foreign
to years that it seems like comes from
another planet.
So this was what Edna Saint Vincent
Millay was telling me was 15 years
absolute and unbelievable punishment is
an advantage
and it will serve you well for the rest
of your life.
You've got a story to tell you then.
This is something I learned from Carl
Young.
So in the,
uh,
in,
in the sharp cathedral in,
in France,
there's a maze and that you walk and
it's at the center point of the
Cathedral.
That's a crucifix essentially.
And so the maze is at the center of the
acts that marks the point of maximum
suffering.
Right now.
It's a symbolic pilgrimage.
And what you do is you,
it amazes a circle.
And in the middle is a symbol that looks
kinda like a rose.
And in order to get to the middle,
which is that central point,
you have to enter the maze and then you
have to walk through the,
the each quadrant.
So you have to circumambulating the
world.
You have to go northwest,
east,
and south.
You have to cover every bit of
territory.
And then you get to the middle.
And the middle is marked by the x,
which is the point,
the point of consciousness,
you might say the center point of the
world,
but also the place where you voluntarily
accept your suffering
sandwiches,
what Christ did.
I mean if I'm not a Christian,
but if you believe in the,
um,
the religion that St Paul created based
on Jesus,
um,
than okay.
God had to become human in to experience
human suffering.
And when Christ was on the cross,
writhing in agony and screamed,
Eli,
Eli Sabachthani,
my Lord,
why Hast Thou forsaken me?
It's because God needed to experience
the absolute extreme of human despair.
Um,
in order to carry out his task of saving
mankind.
Um,
and one way or the other religion talks
to us really about what we need to do.
There's this,
I've got this saying in here,
let me see if I can find it.
Um,
it's not in front of me at the moment,
but it gives me a second as it's very
important.
It's an epigram that I wrote a few years
ago and it says,
since there is no god,
it is our job to do his work.
God is not a beating.
He isn't aspiration,
a gift,
a vision,
a goal to see.
Ours is the responsibility of making a
cool universe turned just of turning
pains to understandings and new insights
into joy,
of creating ways to soar,
the skies for generations,
yet to come,
a fascinating wings with which our
children's children shall overcome,
of making worlds of fantasy materialize
as reality of mining and transforming
our greatest gifts,
our passions,
our imaginings,
our pains,
our insecurities and our lusts.
This is the work of deity and D,
it is a power that resides in us.
In other words,
if these are things that we imagine that
Jesus has done on our behalf and on
behalf of a more ethereal God in the
sky,
these have to be our aspirations,
indeed one of my books,
the genius of the beast,
a radical revision of capitalism and
talks about material miracles,
the very laptops with which we are
having this conversation,
the various zoom with software that we
are using.
These are fucking material miracles,
m and s and we are here to save each
other.
When when Joan jets manager came to me
and said,
Joan has been turned down by 23 record
companies that if you get her just one
line and one of the trade magazines or
record company will snap her up and make
her a star and I can go back.
He said to being a song writer and a
producer and I sat him down on the couch
and said,
Kenny,
that's not the way things happen.
The day they are.
Record come.
No record company is going to sign you
on the basis of one sentence.
The day a record company signs you was
the day your troubles beginning and um,
and you have to fashion a panzer take
tank strategy that can ride over every
obstacle you can possibly imagine.
So if you work the way I worked 17 hours
a day,
seven days a week,
if you do everything I tell you too,
I guarantee you we will have a star in
two years.
One thing that I knew is that I love
rock and roll was going to be a hit.
Now what does that have to do with
secular salvation?
Everything.
Because according to work that was done
with deeper studies and the 19 eighties,
the 19 nineties,
we all cycled through about seven major
mood swings.
A date we adults,
it's more like 22 for kids,
for adolescents,
which means we go from heaven to hell
and back again seven times a day.
If I can succeed in making Joel a star
so that her soul,
I love rock and roll appears on the
radio and you will love that song for
three and a half minutes.
That song is going to Yank you out of
the misery of a personal hell.
That is secular salvation.
If on the other hand,
I'm working with a filmmaker and I've
worked with a bunch of films who can
yank you out of yourself or an hour and
10 minutes or an hour and 50 minutes,
that's an over an hour of sexual or
salvation.
Yeah.
Isn't there always angels playing music
and Heaven,
isn't that?
Yes,
unfortunately it gets very boring up
there because all they do is sing the
praises of God he was doing to,
you know,
exactly making hits we're having.
Yep.
So at any rate,
anything that,
uh,
God can do anything we imagined that a
god can do,
that's our aspiration.
And that's what we have to do our best
to achieve.
Now we don't achieve these things in a
single lifetime.
Sometimes we engage in multigenerational
projects,
the last one,
hundred,
200 or 300 lifetimes,
300 generations.
But flying,
we can see the myth of has flying in it.
Um,
dataless makes a pair of wax wings for
his son,
ICARUS and ICARUS indeed flies.
He just was a little too close to the
solder,
melts the wax and falls into the sea.
So that dream has been around for at
least 2,800
years.
How many generations does it take to
make that real?
I can't even do the arithmetic,
but it took until 100 years ago,
until 110 years ago to make that dream
come true.
If we persist,
and I don't just mean individually,
I mean collectively,
if we persist generation after
generation,
the things we regard as godly,
we can achieve.
We must,
we must go back now.
I'm going to go back.
I agree with you.
I mean I also think that that what and
what do I mean by that?
Well,
well,
I think part of it is this,
that I don't,
I can't see that we have anything better
to do.
No,
in fact,
that's a very good phrase.
This is something I've been talking to
two people about a lot in the last year
and it seems to be resonating
particularly with young men.
Is that because,
and this is maybe partly also tied into
your idea of the benefits of
deprivation,
it's like in some ways each person is
permanently lost because we're fragile
and finite and mortal and all of those
things and so the game is up pretty much
from the beginning,
but one of the things that's so
interesting about that is the fact that
you're going to lose everything.
Also beans that you could risk
everything.
That's a very interesting point,
Jordan,
if the one thing that comes out in your
book,
because I read it a month or two ago,
I know it's not coming out until
something like February is there is a
definite Christian perspective and it is
a stern and austere perspective in in
the book and what you just expressed
comes from a deep Christian perspective.
We're going to lose it all so we might
as well risk at all and I would agree
with that.
Even though I come from a very different
kind of perspective.
How did you arrive at that?
Although we're saving that for a later
podcast when I will interview you about
your book.
Well,
for me it was a matter of trying to
understand.
I would say mostly trying to understand
what happened in the Holocaust.
Go me too.
But that's strange because you're about
10 years younger than I am.
Maybe even more younger than I am.
And well I'm 74.
Okay.
I'm 55 so.
So there's a big difference.
But I did 350 pushups,
so this morning and I was very
disappointed because last week I did
600.
So you've got me on the push up front,
I must say.
Yeah.
So,
but,
but the,
you're absolutely right.
And that phrase of yours,
uh,
there we have nothing better to do.
That's a phrase that indicates an open
ended,
infinity and open ended.
And as yet on structured infinity.
Now it's not completely unstructured.
Remember you.
Your first major work was on the
underlying structures of religion and
I'm still fascinated to read it.
I need to get it in word or PDF format
so I can listen to it on my kindle one
of these days.
I can send it to you.
That would be wonderful.
We could actually,
if you go to my website,
[inaudible] dot com.
You can download the PDF.
Okay,
great.
Because I've been hungry to read this
for a long time,
so the future isn't entirely unformed.
For example,
somehow I believe,
and now this is a hypothesis,
a hypothesis.
We humans seem to know what to do when
we come together in groups of a million
$5,
million,
$10,
$20 million because there are many
cities in China,
uh,
with a population of 20 million.
There's Mexico City as well,
and we fall into it naturally.
We're naturally build the
infrastructures that we need.
We naturally develop the infrastructure
of habit that we need to get along with
each other at that very compressed
level.
And you would think,
well,
but how did that come to be from an
evolutionary point of view?
After all,
humans have never had the privilege of
living groups of millions.
Right?
We're going to all this behavior come
from,
well,
remember our great form others,
the ones who are at the very,
very base of our family tree from whom
we derive.
Approximately 40 percent of our genes
are bacteria and bacteria,
do not live a life alone.
They cannot tolerate it.
They live in groups.
So James Shapiro is one of the great
scholars on bacterial behavior.
When I called him one day and said,
James,
if you drop a single bacterium into a
petri dish isn't going to die because of
isolation.
And he said,
no,
no way it's going to.
It's going to start dividing until it
makes a community.
It surrounds itself with a community.
So the idea that you cannot have a
bacteria without a community is quite
true.
It's just the bacteria,
if they have enough food,
will make their own
similar intuition about cod fish write
fish have disappeared off the
northeastern coast.
Like I've read stories because I did a
lot of work on oceanic appalling oceanic
destruction about four years ago for a,
for a UN committee.
And uh,
anyway,
so I was studying about the cod and
they've all disappeared and the schools
of those things that existed back with
the Europeans first came over.
The Portuguese probably knew about them
before Christopher Columbus even hit the
hit,
the hit the America kept it secret,
but you know,
the schools were dozens or even hundreds
of miles long and many,
many houses the thick and the average
fish was like three to five feet across
and bright,
just densely packed day.
But it turns out that like the idea that
there's a cod fish is an illusion in
some sense.
There are schools of cod fish.
The schools themselves know where to go
for food and they know how to maneuver
through the ocean because the schools
are actually millions of years old and
tributed knowledge and quads.
The cod organize their mating behavior
as a consequence of the existence of the
schools.
And they also organize themselves.
So the larger fish are protected in the
schools by hordes of the younger fish.
And the older fish are the ones that are
more fertile.
The thing about the cod is that when you
get rid of the schools,
you get rid of the card,
you can reintroduce them because the cod
aren't there like ants.
They're not.
They're communal.
Right?
And so once you demolish this old
structure that has this know embodied
memory,
let's say that's who knows how many tens
of millions of years old,
there's no coming back from that,
right?
Well back to the bacteria for a second
because it's a good observation and I
saw a murmuration of starlings last week
in Buffalo,
New York when I was up there for
thanksgiving.
In other words,
groups have probably only about 200
starlings,
but those groups can become a million
and they all know what to do.
They know how to wheel around in a much
broader pattern,
but it all goes back to the bacteria
because bacteria living groups,
a group in the colony,
the size of your palm is 7 trillion,
which is more than all the humans who
have ever lived.
Now there are bacteria like a Reuben,
Osa which come into your body and when
there are small numbers of them lay very
low,
but they're constantly monitoring to see
how many of them there are and when will
they get up to a sufficient number,
whammo they grow through a massive
change and basically it's as if they're
saying,
okay,
now we're big enough to take Jordan
apart and they become infectious and
they create disease,
but they don't do that until quorum
sensing tells them that there are enough
of them to do that.
So,
so is that.
Does that explain why people can harbor
con continue levels of toxic bacteria in
their bodies without ever falling prey
to disease?
Is it a matter of the fact that they,
that they don't hit that core number and
that they're monitoring that constantly?
No.
We have a lot of bacteria that have
adapted to living synergistically with
us and actually do are digesting.
You go down to the market because you
have a craving for chocolate eclairs and
you come back home and you eat one of
the chocolate eclairs and it's not you
who's digesting the chocolate eclair.
You have just acted as a transportation
mechanism to feed a bunch of bacteria in
your gut who will digest that chocolate
eclair and what they shit out his
glucose.
Right?
Well,
it may me.
It may also not be used.
It's craving the damage,
claire,
but the background and the fact is that
the bacteria were just at the beginning
of this research,
but bacteria have an ability to
influence your behavior.
Exactly.
Noted far more than we think.
Right?
Exactly.
So and to engineer in a fine point,
fashion your behavior,
should they so choose basic ideas that
bacteria have been through this business
of living in vast,
vast multitude before and they have
certain social evolve social behaviors,
but turn them into effective groups that
allow them to constantly find new food.
I'm constantly find new housing and if
we think these things are strange to us
because in the 100,000
years since we become Homo Sapiens,
we've never had such a thing until the
last century were crazy because our
ancestors left us 40 percent of our
genes and it is very likely that it
encoded in those genes is a whole world
of how you behave when there are the
kinds of vast masses of tens of millions
that you were talking about on the cob
behavior or the $20 million who are in
Mexico City or in major cities in China.
Part of our genetic potential that's
there not as consequences of human
evolution,
but it's something that preceded that.
Right?
Exactly.
But it's a guest.
This is a hypothesis at the moment.
Let's go back.
Let's go back to you were,
you left your biographical story at the
point where you had finished,
uh,
the art magazine and being successful at
that and then were introduced into the
FM stations.
And so the beginning of the PR firms.
So just to mention it again,
we're actually here talking about how I
accidentally started the six cs and
we've skipped over the whole story of
how I accidentally started the six days.
Well,
we'll get a chance to talk.
We'll get a chance to talk again,
I think because obviously there's things
we could talk about for a very long
period of time.
Oh good.
So basically there I was,
um,
helping get progressive radio off the
ground and I'm also,
when I was 12,
I'm a girl,
had turned her eyes to mine,
was eighth grade.
She turned her eyes to mine and I was
startled because no girl had ever done
that before.
And in fact then she locked into eye
contact and I was even more startled
because I,
that had never happened before either.
And,
um,
and she said,
I told my mother,
you understand the theory of relativity.
Now remember,
I had been in science for two years at
this point,
reading two books a day.
I had annealed copper.
I had made coils.
I had made cold cream from an industrial
formula.
Um,
I had built my or a top design,
my first computer and it won several,
a science fair awards and I had built my
first Boolean Algebra machine.
Oh.
And my mom had schlepped me off to the
University of Buffalo to sit down for
meetings with the head of the graduate
physics department at the University of
Buffalo,
which was probably a courtesy call,
but he was going to allow me five
minutes,
four and I was in there for an hour and
we discussed the hottest topic of the
time,
which was the interpretation of the
doppler shift and big bang versus steady
state theory of cosmology.
That's why he kept me in there because
it was the very year when the chief
champion of steady state theory,
Fred Hoyle knew with absolute certainty
he was about to demolish drawers.
GAM loves theory of the Big Bang,
and it would never be heard from again.
So this was the hottest topic in
science.
And when we got out,
the guy towered over my head and he put
my Santa,
my shoulder and he said to my mom,
you don't have to study for Grad school
or you don't have to save up red school
for him.
He will get graduate fellowships at any
university in.
He wants in theoretical physics.
So it's a good day.
That's a good day.
So I had a history in science already.
And,
and when this girl turned arise to mind,
she said,
I told my mother that you understand the
theory of relativity and I couldn't
confess Jordan,
even though truth,
the truth at any price,
including the price of your life,
is the first rule of science for me.
I couldn't confess that I didn't know
that because what did I have going for
me?
God will forgive you for that.
Well.
So I jumped on my bicycle and I went
down to the library and the librarians
literally knew me better than my mother
did.
And I said,
give me everything you've got on
relativity.
And they shoved to books across the
desk.
Get me a great big fat book by Einstein.
And two collaborators and a little
skinny book by Einstein all by himself.
And I started with the big fat book
because I'd learned at that point in the
life that if you go through something
you don't understand at all and you
shove yourself all the way to the bitter
vicious end,
by the end you come out understanding
something if only on a gut level.
So I was doing that with the big book
and the big bulk head,
about seven words of English on each
page.
And the rest was all mathematical
equations and mathematical equations or
Greek to me.
I've never understood the.
So at 8:00
at night I suddenly realized I'm only 50
pages into this book and my mom's going
to put me asleep at 10:00
tonight.
And if I don't go to school,
understanding the theory of relativity
tomorrow,
I'm going to be humiliated.
So I turned to the little skinny book
and it was written just by Einstein all
on his own.
And there was an introduction to the
book and sometimes it feels as if the
author is stepping out through the
pages,
grabbing you by the lapel.
Putting his nose to yours and shouting a
personal message and in your face,
and that's how it felt.
Einstein grabbed me by the lapels and
said,
listen,
if you want to be a genius,
it's not enough to come up with a
theory.
Only seven men in the world can
understand to be a genius.
You have to be able to come up with that
theory and express it so clearly that
anyone with a high school education and
a reasonable degree of intelligence can
understand it.
So Albert Einstein had told me to be a
writer and so I was operating a writing
career while I was in undergraduate
school and then advancing it when I was.
When I started the art studio is the
goal for me at that point was your next
step to be the writer.
Albert Einstein told you to be is you
would have to write for magazines.
And one day I walked into the office of
a magazine carrying them portfolio,
my art studio,
and wearing an outfit that I bought from
a designer that I was collaborating with
them designing stuff and they have women
at this magazine.
It was a load around magazine called
rags and underground fashion magazine.
It was a bank rolled by one of the
people who bank rolled rolling stone and
the women didn't look at my portfolio.
All they looked at was what I was
wearing.
And they said,
do you have more of those?
And I said,
yes,
I've got a whole closet full of them.
And they said,
can you write an article about that?
Well,
I had been looking for my big break with
magazine writing.
Einstein's imperative.
Was that my back?
Um,
so I said,
of course I can.
And I wrote an article and then I became
a contributing editor on the road.
One hundred and 75 pieces for them.
And then one of the contributing editors
are ordered a new magazine called
natural lifestyles and it may be a
contributing editor there too,
which meant I was getting up at six in
the morning going without a stitch of
clothes on to an old Remington,
1940 is non electric typewriter,
pounding away at writing until eight or
nine going into the art studio.
Getting that up and running and then
coming back home.
And sitting there with a pot of coffee
until 11:00
at night when I put myself to sleep and
I was getting tired of this Jordan.
It had been going on for a year.
So because of the national lampoon,
because there was a great big steady
check coming in every month.
My artists voted me out of my studio.
They didn't want to pay me the
percentage that they owed me.
And for me that was like getting sick.
It was a fortunate thing because I had
been there for three years and I could
have continued there forever running
this art studio and um,
and.
But I was busy writing and one day I was
covering of all things a parapsychology
convention for natural lifestyles.
The other magazine,
I was a contributing editor to sue and I
was taking notes frantically because I
have no memory if I don't know that it's
going to disappear.
And somebody walked up to me and said,
do you want to edit a magazine?
Well,
in my app between my freshman and my
sophomore year of college,
I had gotten a job writing for the boy
scouts of America.
And Britain there,
their chapter,
I've rewritten their chapter on
masturbation for the boy scout handbook
and I'd written that chapters in your
cv.
You have somehow that keeps showing up
and,
and uh,
cause cause remember when I,
when I first got onto science at the
Asia tenant was because of bulk appeared
in my lap and it said the first two
rules of science are these truth at any
price and the price of your life.
And it told the story of Galileo and it
told it all wrong and told it as if he
had been a Giordano Bruno and been
willing to go to the steak.
No,
that's not true.
Then the second rule of science was look
at things right under the noses if
you've never seen them before.
And then proceed from there.
And it gave the story of Anton van
Leeuwenhoek who invented the microscope
and looked at pond water and discovered
these tiny little things called
animalcules microscopic beings.
And he also looked at human sperm.
And then he'd written a letter to the
royal society describing what he had
seen.
Now think about that Jordan.
If it took 30 years before I realized
where he'd probably gotten the humans
from,
and he's confessing this to the Royal
Society story,
right?
So masturbation kept following me
wherever I went,
but I wrote the,
a boy scout book on camouflage that is
there a handbook on camouflage and their
handbook,
they're on stocking,
attracting,
and I had been thrown out of boy scouts
at the age of 11,
competence of Morse Code,
the only child I have ever heard of who
has been thrown out of the boy scouts.
So.
And so I have learned a lesson.
And the lesson was if I care enough
about my audience,
if I want my audience to be able to drop
down on all fours and get so close to a
bunny rabbit using the techniques of
stalking and tracking.
But I teach them that the rabbit doesn't
know they're there until they're rubbing
noses with it,
um,
that I can write anything.
So I didn't ask what the magazine was
about.
When this kid walked up to me and said,
you want to edit a magazine?
And we didn't have google in those days.
So I had the name of the publisher that
I was supposed to set up a meeting with,
but I had no idea who he was and there
was no way to look him up and I had no
idea what his magazine was.
I walked into his office to editors.
We're in the process of packing up their
stuff and leave it on the opposite side
of his office suite from his office.
And I knew nothing about rock and roll.
It turned out that the magazine was
called Circus and it was a rock'n'roll
magazine.
And um,
he asked,
he asked only one question,
can you turn out a magazine in two
weeks,
because he had two weeks before he had
to deliver his magazines and the printer
and his editors were leaving.
And I said yes.
And I turned out the magazine in two
weeks.
And that's how I became the editor of a
rock magazine.
And,
and over the course of time applying
Martin gardeners approach to things,
looking for underlying correlations,
I invented all kinds of correlational
studies that allowed me to get a handle
on my audience.
And I learned that my audience wasn't
interested in the traditional format of
the Rock magazine and my publisher
adhere to,
which is only cover a band that's of
interest to your audience.
Once a year,
I discovered that like the audience for
Time magazine,
which my boss wanted me to imitate and
which I read from cover to cover when I
was a child.
Um,
Time magazine has an article of a
president not once a year,
every single week,
it's a running soap opera.
And if they have a secondary character
like Henry Kissinger,
he's in there at least every other week.
And then there are tertiary characters
who may show up once every four months.
But you need that star trek that a
track,
that presidential track.
And I discovered that my,
that I had one artist that was twice as
popular with my audience as his nearest
runner up.
That was.
And that was Alice Cooper.
And the closest runner up was David
Bowie.
David Bowie looked pathetic by
comparison with Alice Cooper.
So I went to my publisher and I,
I'd taken the sales figures and I'd
worked out additional correlations like
the fact that if we had cover lines,
um,
about people who were in the top 10 on
the album charts the week we came out,
we sold magazines,
which means that with a four month lead
time I had to learn to predict what was
going to be in the top 10 on the album
charts for months in advance.
So I went to my publisher,
I had a complete format for him.
I said,
I guarantee you this is only one of
three statements of this kind I've ever
made in my life.
I guarantee you that if you use this
format,
we will increase the sales of our
magazine.
And he was kind enough to let me get
away with a total overhaul.
And the result was we increased in the
next 12 months,
buy 200,
11 percent.
And my publisher went from a man of
modest means with an apartment on second
avenue overlooking the traffic to a band
of immodest means with a huge aircraft.
Saw anger size apartment overlooking the
East River.
Um,
and,
and chef flip over one of the founding
editors of rolling stone to validate
himself.
He didn't feel well rolling,
stone validated,
sufficiently did a history of rock and
roll journalism for his Masters thesis
at the University of Texas at Austin.
And he sent me six pages by Messenger
one day and it was about this guy
working in a little windowless closet
with a manual remington typewriter
singlehandedly pounding out of a
magazine.
And he said,
single handedly inventing a new
magazine,
the heavy metal magazine.
So that's how I became a scholar of rock
and roll.
I mean,
I buy.
Did you develop an acidity for the
music?
Yes,
I fucking love it.
I had,
who's favorite?
Well,
my favorite before this have been
Vivaldi's winter in the four seasons
because it's angry and scowling and whip
lashing.
And now my favorites became,
well,
my favorite as a person was Michael
Jackson because I never met anybody like
him in my life and never expected to
meet anybody like him.
And he embodied the first two rules of
science in a way that none of the
science people that I've known and loved
have ever embodied it.
And,
um,
my favorites musically right now,
I mean they've changed over the years.
One day I was driving a rental car on
sunset boulevard in Hollywood.
And a song came on the radio that made
me do something I'd never done since I'd
never done before and I've never done
since.
I had to pull the car over to a side,
the side of the road and stop and do
nothing but listen to this song and it
was hurt.
So good by John Mellencamp.
So Billy Joel,
I loved him and his angry period.
But I came to him after his angry period
and one day I wanted to get together
with them socially because I hadn't seen
him in a long time.
And I don't socialize very readily.
I,
I like to get together to work together,
but not necessarily to schmooze
together.
But I did call him for socializing.
So we met for breakfast,
uh,
at a restaurant,
at the outdoor cafe,
part of restaurant on the ground,
ground floor of the Essex House where he
had an apartment and he came down the
elevator carrying this child's notebook,
you know how when you're in first and
second grade,
your parents buy you a black covered
marbled with white notebook to write in.
Well,
he had one of those and he put it in the
middle of the table while we were
talking and he explained something and
he said when I was growing up and we
were teenagers and we would hang out on
the corner just watching all the girls
go by,
um,
girls to us.
We're a separate species.
They were like mules or donkeys or dogs
or something like that.
If we had anything to do with them.
The simple goal was to score.
We assumed that they didn't have brains
like ours.
And I met a girl last night,
billy said,
who utterly defied those rules of what
girls are.
She is articulate,
she is intelligent,
she is on top of things.
She was a pleasure to talk to.
Now Billy had informed me the first time
I met him at his home,
I'm out on a oyster bay that had a piano
room and it had a big grand piano and he
explained that at that writing Sol,
this was like pulling teeth that
sometimes just took them three months to
write a song that he would pace back and
forth panel room and he would call his
piano the beast with Ada teeth.
It was the BC was fighting to get songs
out.
Well,
billy explained that after coming home
at two in the morning for meeting this
astonishing woman,
he had sat down with this little
notebook and he had written an entire
album full of songs.
He made his views it.
Yes.
And it was Christie Brinkley and yes.
And you could see how she might inspire.
So under two.
Yes,
absolutely.
But the point is that it was billy's
most vapid album,
at least to me,
that I'd ever heard from him.
And it's an album that I really am not
interested in listening to,
but his angry period when he was angry
with his first wife,
Elizabeth.
Um,
hey,
those were really,
really good songs.
Paul Simon astonished me.
One day I was in the elevator over at
the Broadway,
whatever it's called,
building Broadway studios or somebody
that I have the building he owns with
Lauren michaels of Saturday night live.
I was in the elevator and I bumped into
Paul who was my client.
I did Simon and Garfunkel reunion tour
in the part or reunion in the park.
And then I did Simon and Garfunkel,
his reunion tour and um,
and Paul had a piece of paper in his
hand and I said,
what's that?
And he said,
it's lyrics roy next album.
Now remember,
I was so heavily in the poetry,
the poetry changed in the nature of my
life when I was 14 to 16 years old and
that I was the editor of a literary
magazine that won two National Academy
of Poets Prizes in addition to the store
caused in the art community.
So I asked if I could see the lyrics.
It's hard to describe this,
but when I read the lyrics,
my knees almost buckled,
which almost felt the floor bones and
stones or something like that.
I'm terrible with album names.
It was some of the most astonishing
poetry I'd ever ever read in my life and
it reached so deep into me that I've
literally was losing control of my body.
Um,
so I asked him if he minded if I showed
these to the lyrics to one friend,
just one friend at the New York Times.
And so he,
we went into his office,
we made a xerox and I walked out with
the Xerox of the lyrics.
Now I had learned that the,
that the media is like sheep and that if
you can take one of the lead shape and
turn him in your direction that you can
change the perception of an artist
within the critical community.
And I had a friend who was an outsider
and yet a lead sheet because he was at
the New York Times and he was an
outsider because he was gay before you
could admit that you were gay.
So even I didn't know that he was gay.
I just trust no,
he was a little bit strange and that I,
as a consequence felt protective of him.
And I called him and said,
I have just seen the most amazing lyrics
I've ever seen in my life,
but for all I know it's an illusion for
all I know.
I have somehow hyped myself into this.
If I send you the lyrics,
can you tell me if I'm crazy?
And two hours later I send it to them by
Messenger.
In two hours later I got a phone call
saying,
you are not crazy.
So Paul Simon has amazing astonishing
gifts.
And beyond that,
I mean I love rock and roll and blues
based service.
So these days I'm listening to Joe
Bonamassa and Johnny Lang and Beth Hart,
who I think is the best vocalist I've
ever heard in my life.
Yeah,
Beth Hart is just amazing.
She takes everything that,
uh,
at uh,
James did and everything that Janis
joplin builds on the,
on the base of what I had james had done
and takes it five levels beyond what
whoever thought any vocals could ever
made your praise because there's editor
James was quite the creature.
She really was.
She was an original.
So that's.
But,
but we skipped the story of how I
accidentally started the six days.
Let's do that.
That's a good place to stop.
I think because we got into.
Well,
we completed the story.
We completed that story.
I would love to talk to you again.
It was an absolutely great conversation
and for me it's a privilege because I
love your thinking about Muse,
about religion in terms of its
underlying archetypes because that's a
part of my life quest.
But you've gone out and explored a part
that I would never have had the time to
explore with a mind that's yours.
And so it's going to be different than
mine.
So I will download the PDF.
I'm hope.
I hope that.
Well,
especially because you've read the
second book,
there's 12 rules for life that should
open up maps of meaning,
if which is a much more.
Um,
I would say it's a much denser book.
It's probably not as well written,
although I think it's,
it's,
I'm not complaining about it.
It it accomplish the goal that I'd set
out to accomplish,
which was,
well,
you'll,
you,
you've experienced some of it with 12
rules for life and I'd be very
interested to hear what you have to say
about maps of meaning.
So let's talk again while you're going
to talk to me.
I think in January that was the plan,
right?
Um,
yes,
we were in a talk in January or February
when the bankers out sat in another talk
somewhere.
Um,
yeah.
Are you in New York?
I'm in New York.
I'm sitting here in park slope,
Brooklyn.
Well,
maybe if you wouldn't mind the next time
I come down to New York,
we really.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Let me know as far in advance as
possible because my gala and we'll do
it.
Okay,
good.
I love that.
Okay.
You've been a pleasure.
It's been really good talking to you and
it was,
it was really a lot of fun and you're,
you're,
you're an amazing font of stories and,
and interesting tangents and,
and crazy schemes and adventures.
It's really,
like I said,
if you didn't exist,
it would be hard to.
Hard to invent you,
so I shall see you sometime in the next
two months.
Good.
All right.
Thanks Jordan.
You have a great night.
Okay,
see Ya.
Bye.